this morning on the dish a woman who
turned a popular food blog into a
personal brand
gabby delkin was working as a private
chef when she launched what's gabi
cooking back in 2009
it soon became her full-time job
expanding into instagram
stardom and now her third cookbook eat
what you want came out this spring
showcasing what she calls recipes for
real life with no deprivation
jamie yukin spoke with delkin about her
food philosophy
at her new home in l.a
what's gabby cooking hi today a lot
gabi dalkin had hoped she would be
entertaining friends in her brand new
kitchen
but today she just gets me socially
distanced
what i do like about your cookbook is
that it's called eat what you want
and i think in quarantine we're all
eating what we want that is true
yours is a little bit cleaner and
healthier yeah i mean but i think
for me like i think food brings people
so much joy
is that why we should have blueberry
skillet cake for breakfast balance
the book in gabi's life is all about
balance
even in a pandemic upending everything
what do you think this is delicious
it's so moist right i love it because it
almost tastes like
the moistest blueberry muffin but with
that really crisp topping
topping that's exactly what i wanted to
be like her latest book has 125 of
gabi's signature recipes
all a mashup of bright flavors and
hearty satisfying ingredients
and i'm going to make you pizza
pizza salads and palomas these are some
of my favorite recipes from the new
cookbook
and i feel so happy i get to cook for
you because i haven't cooked for anybody
in
so many weeks our menu today her
watermelon cucumber salad
an la chop also known as an italian
salad
is full of chickpeas italian cheeses and
genoa salami
her dad's kitchen sink cookies featuring
oats m m's
chocolate chips and dried fruits i mean
i knew you were coming over
this is what a typical morning looks
like even the garlic and kale pizza
seems
easy especially when you don't need to
worry about making your pizza dough from
scratch
you just buy it at a good italian deli
so i like spread it out with my fingers
on the edges and then i just take
my fingers underneath and kind of pull
it out this way
i'm not sure if this is how like any
real peepsiolo
would do it but this works for me are
you sure there's enough cheese
i mean you want to add a little bit more
no it's okay i think we're good
so now we're going to take this out take
this outside and it's going right into
the pizza oven
and it's really only going to take 60
seconds 60 seconds
it's gonna it's gonna boggle your mind i
can't wait
so it's 900 degrees 900 degrees it's
insane you could and you could do
anything in it you could do pizza you
could do chicken you could do fish you
could do vegetables
that's so simple and then it'll go right
on
our cutting board as we sit down to
enjoy the feast we're joined by gabi's
husband
and business partner thomas the two have
created instagram platforms that make
the most popular
influencers envious and with most of the
country home
and cooking their social media presence
is up more than 300 percent
since the beginning of the pandemic the
salmon's perfectly cooked
not the least bit fishy did you ever
think this would turn into this whole
empire no i mean when i was pre-med in
college i had no intention of going into
the food world
switched to business after i failed an o
chem test and then when i got to
culinary school it was very much just to
cook for
us and our friends and i wanted to learn
how to just be a better cook myself
and then it very slowly snowballed and i
got a job as a private chef and i
started my blog
my mom was the only person reading my
blog for a very long time
what is the difference in flavor between
shallots versus
red onions can you use either or you can
use either or i
ask a lot of questions and actually
think the questions that i have
are what a lot of other people have when
they're watching your insta lives yeah
and so i just ask away and i think
everybody
hopefully benefits from my cluelessness
in the kitchen well you learn a lot and
everyone else learns a lot we're
teaching everyone how to cook one thing
at a time
don't think the pandemic is stopping
these two each day there is fresh
content
new recipes and laughter in the new
house
no but people were stressed watching us
that gives them a reason to keep going
and having
all of us eating what we want it's
pretty special it's fun
we're here here's to many more years
cheers
i want to be there looks good it's a
real cheers you just can't touch the
glasses right that pizza amazed you
i know right so it's 900 degrees and you
put it in for one minute
you just need the pizza oven out there
to do you just need the pizza oven to
actually do it
great stuff from gabi though and jamie
all right